what would you say is the Fate your
favorite role that you've played and all
these things I've talked about what is
the one that you just think I gotta say
this one this is the oh man because
there's different questions I want to
know what's the most challenging role
you've played yeah what's the the role
that you really look at and you're like
I just love playing this guy I wanna I
wanted to continue playing this guy oh
there's man there's a lot you know it's
uh I love being on Parenthood I loved I
who that character was he's very close
to who I am so so you know I I also
I like what I learned on certain shows I
guess I don't I guess I don't it's not
necessarily the character that I I'm
like oh man I'm gonna miss that
character
um because I they're still I feel like
they're still part of who I am and but
um but I I miss experiences you know I
miss and and
um handmaids is a great example of like
I I have this very particular role he's
kind of stoic and keeps to himself and
holds all his cards and uh there's a
lesson there you know for me which is
you know watching Lizzie moss do her
work there's a Stillness and a
specificity she has
that uh and still a tenacity you know
she's present but she's always she's
always aware of what the camera is doing
and how and her effect on it and I think
I can learn from that so I just try to I
just keep trying to learn you know
really so you learn from everything yeah
or else you know
what's the point you know I've seen I
remember seeing the actors I loved from
the 70s do projects that I was like I
don't know what I mean this is a
paycheck and uh that has to be done like
you said yet family care for and stuff
but I I I just wanna I wanna keep
learning and kind of tricking myself or
proving myself in a way that surprises
myself and others you know
foreign